[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chrissy how we doing with mike is mike
going to be able to join us there todd
said right now we can give it a try all
right let's give it a try i think our
first guest we've ever had on from italy
mike piazza the hall of famer where are
you in italy
i am in uh parma parma italy okay north
yes like parmigiano reggiano parma ham
how is your italian
ah it's good enough it's good enough if
i want to get fed and uh if i want to
get
if i want to get a ticket or need a
coffee or ask for directions i would say
it's plus conversational
higher than conversational but not quite
fluent enough to get around and survive
all right uh if i ask you to pronounce
mozarella would you pronounce that
mozzarella
all right
judge would you judge seton's uh italian
no he's not italian he's irish but but
he's working on his italian his wife's
italian all right see go ahead
yeah a lot of people it's funny i've
learned that the american version of
italian food is pretty funny
there's actually been a lot of youtube
videos and people talking about
pronunciation yeah but if you try to say
you come here and you say mozzarella
they'll they you won't get served
[Laughter]
is there an olive garden in uh in parma
i don't think so i think if they opened
an olive garden here it probably
wouldn't do pretty well
to be kind because i did you know i did
make uh we've made our our minor league
checks stretch very long on the free
breadsticks and the salad but uh in
italy i don't think it would do well
although they do have a starbucks here
now in milan which a lot of people said
starbucks when starbucks wouldn't
survive here but
it's not your typical starbucks it's
it's very very high-end so
i imagine they have to up the quality a
little are you full-time
italian resident
yes i have two passports and my kids
have been in school here about four
years uh the kova deer obviously was
very difficult for everybody but uh
yeah i mean it's just something my wife
and i wanted to do completely different
and just
kind of change the culture and they're
very fluent in italian i'm actually
taking my kid to soccer practice tonight
uh after after we get off so he's uh
playing soccer he scored a goal the
other day which is kind of cool he's not
really a striker he's kind of a skilled
midfielder who follows up the play so
it's a great experience for him and and
now that things are getting back to
normal you know it's a little easier to
go back and forth
he's uh one of the great catchers of all
time 12-time all-star uh hall of famer
mike piazza joining us from parma uh we
wanted to have you on uh to talk about
the technology that we're seeing
baseball introduce with catchers here
that apparently
trying to cut down on sign stealing
your thoughts on uh is it an
overreaction
uh slightly
i did see that new device in spring
training i was in mets camp uh a while
ago i think a little less than two weeks
ago and i saw that new device that
they're putting in the ear and the
catcher and the second baseman and
shortstop and pitcher obviously a lot of
pitchers i i didn't know what was coming
anyway i just kind of said i'm better
look fastball and adjust to anything
else
i i think uh it's a shame that that that
sign stealing controversy did happen i
didn't i didn't think it was very uh
it just wasn't part of the game and
unfortunately the game has not been able
to police itself like in the years past
and um
guys are
i think a little bit now very
overreacting a little sensitive to it i
don't really think it's rocket science i
think
as a hitter i guess more on location
than actual pitch
but since hitters now i think are
really guessing or since there's
less of an emphasis on strikeouts the
guys are swinging harder with two
strikes so they kind of
are trying to to it's more of a of a
problem i guess so than it was in the
past but uh
you know i'm all for technology the game
has changed i feel a little bit like a
dinosaur but and i think it's
interesting i think it could be a place
but
my whole thing is too that if if it is
uh an electronic device maybe that could
be hacked or compromised as well
so
you know we were i was saying if
we could hear it through some sort of
radio wave or something then the other
side could probably hear it too
if they really wanted to so that
presents another issue of problems
obviously yeah i just wondered about you
know
sign stealing is part of the game
like just actual looking in to see what
you know location or
fastball curve ball whatever you you
consider that part of the game
well i would say part of the game but
also disguising it as part of the game
and then if you felt like the guy was
overtly flaunting
relaying it to the hitter then obviously
i've had a few conversations where
catchers told me is he telling you the
signs because uh
it could be very dangerous uh but
since that is not no longer
it's frowned upon obviously and
maybe it's
for the better for the worse i don't
know i mean i'm more of a traditional
guy i always felt like those things were
naturally policed and then there was
some pictures i mean like oral
herscheiser during his stretch in 1988 i
believe when they won the world series
you're probably going to get a sinker
you know what i mean it wasn't it wasn't
like a big mystery
you were probably going to get a sinker
and especially with maddox as well i
mean i think the location part was
probably more
of something at least for me if i knew
the guy was coming inside he probably
wasn't going to come inside with a
change up it was probably going to be
something pretty firm so if i knew that
i kind of already had
more or less 50 percent of the of my
guessing kind of uh eliminated did you
have a pitcher who tipped his pitches
yeah that's well that's i think also
another problem that hasn't been
addressed where um eric harris who we've
talked about before was amazing at in
the stretch when the pitcher had his
hand up
they sometimes would dig for a certain
pitch like if a guy was going for a
slider he would rotate his wrists and no
carols would go to me after the second
inning and and he would say do you want
the pitches and i would say really and i
said yeah and he would say dude fastball
you know curveball or fastball changeup
or fastball split and
he and ravi alamar were two guys that i
remember distinctly would have the
pitches and then
with the advent of free agency we
actually found out that some of our
pitchers who knew guys on the other team
were telling them that oh they have your
pitches in the stretch because
you know again if guy went for a change
up he would dig or you would see his
hand you know manipulate the ball a
little bit differently so
that that was a problem as well some
guys were overly obvious about it even
guys on their own team could sometimes
see it
um
and also telling a picture i remember uh
mark grace told me that they they
realized randy johnson was tipping his
pitches
and nobody wanted to tell randy that he
was tip like they were always worried
about randy getting mad
and but that you know they were in fear
of him and they were teammates but you
know they didn't want to tell especially
on the days that he was pitching because
randy was a different animal those days
yeah i mean that's the thing my
daughter's young just a second honey i'm
on the inter i'm having an interview
good lord sorry about that
[Laughter]
she's like dad dad i'm like i'm doing it
how old is she
she's 12. oh okay but
yell at her in italian mike yeah yeah
i'm saying
i'm on an interview here
say hi
no she's shocked
mama mia keep fighting
yeah the part um randy no randy was an
intimidating guy and uh just to finish
your thought on him but yeah and i could
see i would be scared too if i was
catching him because you know he'd
probably get mad at me or at least you
know feel like i was doing something to
tip his pictures which obviously wasn't
the case uh take us back to the baywatch
performance
you're on the dodgers
you're wearing you're wearing your
jersey and your hat you're swinging a
bat on the beach
so how do they how do they pitch that to
you mike
well actually that was right after the
strike uh occurred and it was september
and eric harris and i were kind of
getting delirious and we were we didn't
really know if we were going to go back
to play if there was going to be a world
series obviously the world series didn't
happen that year which was
which was a tragedy in itself but i mean
i just kind of
didn't take myself too seriously it was
just out of fun you know i knew we was
going to come across a little bit corny
but i just figured you know what i'm in
la and i thought it would be cute and i
didn't realize in this day and age
and then back then there was no social
media i mean we had the brick phones you
know what i mean it was like we had the
analyze so i'm like thinking oh no one's
ever going to see this again it's just
going to go into the dustbin of history
and now even today with social media i
you mention it now i it gets mentioned
all the time so i tell people you know
when you do something
that you may or may not regret it does
stay with you for a very long time and
and you did help save that woman who was
in the water needed rescue you and you
and pam anderson yeah protector
i did it was it was she was very yeah i
felt like i was doing a good deed and uh
yeah
helping a young lady and a very
attractive young lady in a bikini
drowning in two feet of water
uh it was yeah so that's i tell people
all the time it's hard work but somebody
has to do it i just love the the shot of
you you're so serious you're taking your
cuts and pam anderson is saying hey you
know you can't be swinging a bat on the
beach
and then i'm mike piazza and then she's
like okay just don't hit anybody and
then that's when you had to
go to the rescue of this poor woman in
distress in the ocean i mean really it's
a it's remarkable did you get any awards
for that
[Music]
oh
well we're on a freeze up there
maybe it's best that we leave it at that
little bit of mystery yes you got to
leave the mystery mike thank you for
joining us we appreciate it